venom and spider-man in one movie is
something that we have all been waiting
for for a very long time especially with
Tom Hollands spider-man and Tom Hardy's
venom two characters who people love
very much what's up everyone it's Warren
and with the sony disney deal having
just come to a completion it is possible
that we could see venom and spider-man
in a movie now although we are not 100%
sure of what is included in this deal it
has been heavily speculated that the two
universes could have a crossover we know
that Sony originally wanted spider-man
in venom but Marvel said no but they
just worked a new deal so maybe in that
deal includes the ability for a shared
universe and it seems like Tom Hardy may
have recently teased a crossover with
venom and spider-man real quick don't
forget to subscribe to my channel leave
a like and comment down below so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 so a few people
noticed that Tom Hardy posted this
picture on Instagram of him dressed as
spider-man and then deleted it now of
course everybody that saw this started
to immediately freak out thinking that
it is a tease for a spider-man and venom
crossover now there's kind of two
different scenarios that could be
happening here
one is that it's Halloween and he could
be dressing up a spider-man for
Halloween however if that were the case
he probably wouldn't have deleted the
photo and the photo probably would have
been a little bit different than this
one so that leaves the other scenario
that there actually could be a
spider-man venom crossover event that
could happen pretty soon or in the near
future at least because some of you may
recall that he actually confirmed Andy
Serkis as the director from venom two
days before it was announced and he did
it in the same fashion he posted a photo
on Instagram and then he deleted it so
could Tom Hardy possibly be doing the
same thing here is he teasing that
spider-man could be in venom too because
again Sony wanted spider-man in venom
they actually filmed a scene for venom
that had Tom Holland in it but
unfortunately Marvel didn't let him use
it they didn't want people to think that
venom was in the MCU
but maybe Sony worked out a deal with
Marvel stating that if spider-man is
going to
remain in the MCU they want him to
appear in a venom movie and the next
thing from Sony in the spider-verse
slash venom vs venom
so perhaps Tom Hardy has let something
slip again by posting something to
Instagram and then deleting it after or
perhaps he is simply dressing up as
spider-man for whatever reason so let me
know what you think do you think that he
is teasing some sort of a crossover here
fans have wanted it for a very long time
Sony has wanted it so maybe Marvel has
caved and they're going to let
spider-man enter the venom Merce leave
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below also give the video a like if
you enjoyed it and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel for your chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram for
other giveaways as well and as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff